io ti do quest'anno che te la do no no
no così bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
a questo nuovo video sono fa vj e non ci
siamo tornati sua rinuncia
siccome è tipo da secoli che non ci
gioco 15 ho perso una mano in una
maniera incredibile tipo devi provare un
paio di mosse giusto per ricordarmi come
cazzo ci si muove perché da un attimo
che non mi ok ok ok qui siccome si
rallenta tempo perfetto ci sia un regalo
sono diventato più forte di quanto mi
ricordassi non mi ricordo benissimo come
si gioca sta roba
quindi perdonatemi se faccio cagate di
questa sera su cover e lo sai quanto mi
dispiace prendersi a schiaffi per la
cosa che mi riesce meglio exor basta che
cazzo topico [ __ ] de vito è bravo
così ragazzi dovete capire che dovete
farvi clocks i vostri ok perfetto presto
il di bello li sto gioco e quando non se
l'aspettano li piglia schiaffi e
bellissime sono andati a sono lì
perfetto e si randellano come cani cioè
anzi come conigli io l'ho fatto un cazzo
è arrivato gli ho tirato una pedata ma
ho vinto io mi ricordava neanche lui ci
si muoveva in sto gioco quindi mazzate
girato la testa e la madonna
no mi sono fatto niente non mi sono
fatto fermi che devo andare al rallenty
devo fare il figo o tengono comminato il
cazzo guardalo madonna madonna chi è
culata inutile a terra
sono morto sono da solo ma il potere del
getto no non è questo gatto sta da te
questo gatto no questo e conigli conigli
ancora è che cazzo ecco qui non è che
questo neanche questo
ecco i ragazzi dopo secoli l'ho preso
quota perfetto morgan un giorno schivati
tutti grati tutti caso ma hanno fatto un
culo così e bello ragazzi quando quando
riesco a fare le mie mosse speciali uno
contro uno ma questo è un cane porca
[ __ ] che cosa ho scelto mi chiedi a
botta madonna wallonne guardie madonna
casa ha fatto la lega basta
dopo questa dopo questa mi ritiro sono
il campione del mondo indiscusso
credibile si gira ferma al tempo che la
voglia la voglio lo voglio voglio ma non
l'ho preso l'ho tra passato come ho
fatto a lutto pezzo di merda ragazzi è
tornato in vita non si sa è un vampiro
probabilmente amy parecchi colpi e tu mi
ha rubato le forchette vero sei stato tu
a rubarmi le crocchette lurido stronzo
perfetto è stato lui ragazzi è stato lui
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] pensa
che gli è bastata che cos'è sta roba
ragazzi è una io posso scegliere no
fermi un attimo a io scelgo questo che
non so che cos'è ma lo piazza a terra
perché figo o piazzato un fungo che
questa roba eh vabbè nato sei stronzo
stai fermo devi stare fermo quando io
guardo le cose donna come cazzo ti
permetti ragazza allora fermi che lui
lui cerca vaffan
ma che cazzo ma chi sei jackie chan
ragazzino e lui non so chi non so chi
cazzo di me è fortissimo ma io li faccio
un culo così vinto io a caso infatti
capire che cos'è sta roba che non ho
capito ma sorpresa nicchia che culo
ragazzi ho messo il coltello anche come
ho messo una roccia nel mezzo non
chiedetemi perché ma fa fitto non puoi
salire sulla mia roccia stronzo è
bellissimo perché ci provano cds panarea
perfetto ho fatto la figura dell'idiota
all ennesima potenza tanto mi sono non
mi sono svegliato mi fanno che bastardi
di merda attaccato a un tizio a terra
come non detto ai ragazzi adesso
facciamo due conti in due
facciamo amava tanto questo non c'è più
la facciamo vian mela diesel a me me la
g sarà mai mi ha tagliato una scelta
come si fa a mettere le spade non si
possono mettere le spade a si possono
mettere sulla amica che cazzo è sta roba
cos'è un martello ragazzi voi voglio un
martello subito su come si fa a mettere
martin o terminati o lega per fermi cui
si raccoglie come si era fatemelo
raccoglie no è il mio martello non vale
così vasta
no eh vabbè sei stronzo però mi ha
[ __ ] al mart è quello il mio martello
top
morgan si gioca su cosa riuscito a
batterlo senza martello e lui col
martello fantastico voglio il mio
marzella adesso non me ne vado di qui
finché non c'è il mio martello cosa
eccolo qua perfetto ragazzi e chi è che
vuole un po di marzo ha dato come fa a
tenerlo ci spiega temi concreti perché
c'era anche lui e cos'è torre contro bob
l'aggiustatutto vieni qui para colpo a
morte la e vabbè ma non tirare calci
sociali martello mi causa lo lui tira i
ragazzi qui c'è il martello ma tira i
calci non so perché fai un martello e
per i calci e pugni perché ci siamo
ragazzi voglio provare la modalità che
non l'ho ancora provata la modalità
versus che tipo ci tiriamo mazzate come
se
come videogiochi old style sì ma si
muove sto tizio ragazzi sto combattendo
contro un manichino cosa giro giro tondo
gasc al mondo casca al muro il coniglio
lo piglia arthur ashe anche una spada
pattern c'è allora tu sei stupido come
la marcia ma muoviti fa qualcosa ragazzi
ecco è come giocare contro manichine mi
da anche punti la sopra che cazzo mi dai
punti che non si muove sto stronzo
io ti do quest'anno che te la do
perfetto no no no ho vinto io non avevo
intenzione di dartelo in testa tipo ma
che cazzo fa era a casa bellissima
ragazzi io lo amo straw cosa c'è il
fermi un attimo mi piace mira che cazzo
di miraggio regalo fatemi provare
un'altra cosa che è bellissimo c'è che
poi lui la lascia cadere l'arma e gli
finisce in testa che mira assurda ma un
po più ostile il nemico cioè possibile
tra di loro combattono però ragazzi
state per assistere all'omicidio con il
10 di eboli perfetta esecuzione in
diretta in chiamati faction culo di
quelli che te lo ricordi per tutta v
come cazzo da morire a quello sta fermo
dal mattino alla sera io sono riuscito a
morire sulla mia spada ma [ __ ]
posso mettere no va bene lo sapevo
questo ci metto lui che combatte infatti
si è finalmente mica ci voleva tanto
ragazzi ho trovato il degno avversario
che tanto mi ha fatto anche un culo così
noi partiamo pericolosa
losone arriva da dietro a caso aiuta
d
il nido rimonti aragao ho trovato un
degno avversario dopo ora e allora lui
significa un cazzotto non avete idea
però c'è l'altro teche che mi sembra un
po più incazzato mi sa ecco con lui con
lui c'è battaglia [ __ ] fermi fermi
farmi eccolo prezzo adesso voglio
parlare la mostra pica che ho provato
cinque minuti fa ce la faccio ecco che
porta in faccia gli ho dato x mi fermi
farmi vermi ma perché lui perché
ma che cazzo non è possibile noi rotto i
[ __ ] mai rotto i [ __ ]
e che cazzo eppure tu [ __ ] ti
sembra camere manca una poi ho vinto
perché non ne posso più luca sommi che
adesso ti trascina sulla roccia
antistupro vivo prendere lo era il lupo
eccoli perfetto calcio in culo potente
ce l'abbiamo fatta lega con creature che
possono chiudere qui perché è stata è
stata la battaglia epocale questo è
sicuro però ti può prendere ammazzati
miei compagni è una cosa bellissima
non avrò mai abbastanza portato ragazzi
questo ciò che ancora in alpha quando
usciranno muso pensare che cazzo ci
mettono perché già così è figo non oso
pensare dopo un ragazzino per oggi
conclude p episodio come al solito
ragazza il video è piaciuto il suo
sgomento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e condivide o tratto nella
descrizione dei vari siti scrivete noi
ci rivediamo le pressioni d'opera
ragazzi